finalmente ha despegado la misión
artemis rumbo a la luna pero hasta
prácticamente los últimos 10 minutos
antes del lanzamiento no se sabía con
certeza si iba a despegar desde aquí
desde el centro espacial Kennedy ya que
a última hora se han presentado unos
problemas técnicos con los radares
después de todo los ingenieros
encargados del despegue daban luz verde
para que se iniciara el viaje a la luna
pero esta misión va mucho más allá de
regresar a la luna 50 años después
artemis está formado por el cohete sls
que es el más caro el más potente y el
más grande que jamás ha ido al espacio
tiene una altura de 98 metros o que
equivale a un edificio de más de 30
pisos y pesa más de 84 toneladas también
por la cápsula orión que tiene una
capacidad mayor de hasta cuatro personas
y podrá viajar mucho más lejos que en
los años 70 llegando hasta 64.000
kilómetros de la cara más lejana de la
luna en este primer viaje es un viaje de
pruebas sin tripulación y tiene como
objetivo analizar la situación sobre el
terreno para que en unos dos o tres años
se pueda enviar de nuevo los seres
humanos al satélite la última vez fue
con la misión del Apolo 17 hace ya más
de medio siglo pero este proyecto lo que
pretende Es que la luna pueda
convertirse en una especie de estación
de servicio para los viajes que se
realicen entre la Tierra y Marte esto es
solo el principio y aún se deberán
realizar algunos lanzamientos de prueba
antes de enviar de nuevo seres humanos a
la luna no será hasta por lo menos 2024
y en ese entonces Se volverá a hacer
historia porque Se enviará la primera
mujer y a la primera persona de minoría
étnica